um you know when you and katie were
working out everybody made a very big
deal about the photo and i don't really
think people understand what the
offseason in l.a is like everyone is
working out together um so just talk
about that photo that moment and that it
was what it actually was for you it goes
back to your earlier question like what
did you give up being jason tatum it's
like they exaggerate everything i do
right i've known katie since i was in
high school
we were on the usa team together we
spent
five weeks together last year from vegas
to tokyo we won a gold medal like you
know we have a a bond like that's my
brother
um
and it's like
i'm not too proud to say katie is one of
the best players ever so if like
one of the best players wants to work
out with you and i could learn some
things for him like why would i say no
and it's just
if you worry about if you worry too much
about what other people think you're
going to say you'll drive yourself crazy
yeah
and it's crazy that
i can't work out with somebody
no yeah that's all we was working out
together yeah um you know trying to get
better yeah